it ran accounted for 3% of global oil
supplies last month how much of that is
going to be lost to the market now do
you think well it could be a lot less
than people fear SP global plot
analytics we're predicting that by the
fourth quarter about 200,000 barrels a
day of Iranian crude could be displaced
as a consequence of that to put that
into context that's about a quarter of
what's being pumped out of the North Sea
at the moment so in a 100 million barrel
a day oil market which is what demand is
expected to be this year it's it's it's
relatively small
chunsu an awful lot so why is the oil
price gone up to the extent that it has
done well that's a good question and
it's gone up because the actual market
is very finely balanced you know the the
balance between supply and demand now
we've had a few years of OPEC cuts that
have drained global stockpiles that has
had an effect on markets producers many
of them are struggling to maintain
capacity there hasn't been a lot of
investment in the industry so
disruptions like this they're not
expected and the market is very finely
balanced and that really does explain
some of these price fluctuations that
we've seen as I suppose we're gonna see
any OPEC producers falling over
themselves to make good this shortfall
well you know it's a market opportunity
you know for countries like Saudi Arabia
which is the world's biggest exporter
this is an opportunity to step in and to
take some of that market share it's been
fighting with Iran in the oil markets to
gain a foothold more of a foothold in in
crucial markets like Asia China and
whatever bowels are lost out of Iran and
you can be sure that countries like
Saudi whoever will try and step in yeah
interesting I mean about 15 percent of
Iran's output it's currently bought by
the Chinese do you think they'll carry
on buying it on on under-the-counter
basis I think it's very difficult and
and the Chinese market is all-important
now you look at the fundamentals of
supply and demand which we tend to
concentrate on it SMP Global plots the
Chinese market saw a 15 percent increase
last month in imports of crude so it's
very strong demand there they need the
oil so there was definitely an incentive
for them to do that but it's very
difficult and the way that these
sanctions worked in the past it's not so
much the the
stop stopping oil trades that's the
problem it's the intermediaries it's
very difficult to clear transactions
it's very difficult to clear dollar
transactions if you saw in the last
round of sanctions that affected Iran
the bank's you know a lot of them were
hit very hard with penalties by the US
government for doing trading in in Iran
in some form so I find it very difficult
to see how how companies would want to
take those risks but could this give an
impetus to trade oil in other currencies
such as a remand be all the Euro well
that's a very good question and it's
been talked about a long time there's
been a lot of talk historically that
major oil producers would shift away
from the dollar to a basket of
currencies but we live in a US dollar
denominated world finances is governed
by the US dollar I don't see that
changing energy more than anything is
very much a US dollar industry what
about the position of total in all this
I mean of all the foreign oil producers
they were the ones who probably staked
most on arraign Iran being brought in
out of the cold where does this leave
them after all this well you would argue
it could leave the mix but leave them
somewhat exposed however they only dip
their toes in the water you know we're
talking about mo use it's very unclear
how much actual investment they put on
the ground it was a gas development that
they were looking at certainly they were
not alone in being amongst the
international companies to to test the
waters there in Iran I think that they
should be able to extricate themselves
from this if they have to and of course
you know they've got a quite diverse
portfolio across the Middle East as well